NFL running back Leonard fournette
escapes his SUV after it catches fire
while he's driving the aftermath caught
on body camera video in Florida
what's up man are you all right man yo
foreign
[Applause]
it happened on June 27th in Tampa the
former Tampa Bay Buccaneer and LSU Tiger
posted to his Instagram showing the
charred Dodge Durango after the fire
body camera video captures First
Responders arriving on the scene when
the vehicle was still covered in flames
oh
the brake lights brake light
the brake lights is going on
the vehicle
anybody in there
get out the vehicle
can you hear me
[Music]
the only thing they know what's in there
okay someone's in there
video from another first responder shows
these same moments from a different
angle
[Music]
[Applause]
it's too late
is there someone inside
is there someone in there
is there
hey
get out of the vehicle
is there someone in there
gosh damn it
hey
okay
is this your vehicle man
did we already call for fire rescue
after First Responders make sure there's
no one inside the vehicle fernet
approaches he explains he was driving on
I-275 when he noticed flames in his rear
view mirror
you guys
I'm looking out the back the back mirror
I see planes coming from the back so at
the top and they can't know what I
thought playing standing from the front
of it
is this your vehicle
what's up man are you all right man yo
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
stop these two things how much fuel did
you have in it oh like gas wise yeah
you're full it's cool yeah
all right
these same moments are shown from
another angle it's your vehicle yeah
hey no one else is in there no nothing
but I was talking about my man I've got
it I just got that called built and my
exhaust was tripled messing up a little
bit and it'll make a noise when I was
driving it just caught on fire from the
back yeah
all right I'm gonna get my vehicle block
off these two because this thing's how
much fuel did you have in it
yeah cool
cool oh great
hey get your vehicle like put it all
down the other side
if you can
[Applause]
early on First Responders admit they
recognize fernet that's the running back
former running back from Tampa Bay
Atlanta
what's up
you say he had a little custom-made or
whatever
tell me that was winning fournette yeah
you know who that is right yeah I know
who that is I'm like I don't know
the first reaction was like what does he
think we're driving something like this
that's what I'm thinking you know that
you know who that is right yeah okay
yeah I was like my first reaction was
like what does he do with driving
something like this I figured hit me in
a Ferrari or something
wow
hey at least he's okay yeah later body
camera video captures First Responders
asking for net about his career
making noise
officials can then be seen securing the
area diverting traffic as fire Crews
work to put out the blaze
on fire
well thank god he's okay and there's no
one else
the brake lights go like back and forth
press going in there
a fire rescue
he said he's got a full tank of gas I
told someone
oh my God
big life
if you guys want to start converting
people think right now you're selling
the whole thing off huh bro you got it
I'm a nice car pass back and there's no
way in hell they're gonna have to they
could go back there's no way they're
gonna be able to get all right so let
him know
are they gonna have to wait they're
gonna have to wait and stuff like that
yeah they're about we're gonna get one
later yeah
there's one lane okay
you're gonna get one thing because it's
gonna be harder to burn all these people
oh
[Applause]
that's good we good
awesome
you're gonna get two open
[Music]
yeah
wow
hey at least she's okay yeah
oh
yeah
officials can then be heard telling
fernet what's next for his vehicle yeah
it's gonna be told
I'm here on Florida Highway Patrol
she'll be coming
and they'll they're gonna have the toll
and all that
I'm glad you're good bro
no one was injured in the fire and right
now the cause is still undetermined
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie